it is hard to believe but one of the
biggest shopping days of the year Black
Friday is right around the corner but it
actually starts now at Chapman
Automotive the sponsors of this segment
Don habrick the president of Nevada
operations is here to tell us more
welcome back Todd good to be back
Mercedes I love when I said wait Black
Friday is starting now and you said why
wait exactly you guys are getting
started tell us about some of the deals
that you have right now these Black
Friday deals here you don't have to wait
because we're going to do it now so Rams
up to 11 000 off on Rams and you know
it's crazy because a lot of people don't
have the inventory we're fortunate we do
we're passing the deals on zero percent
financing on our Dodge Durangos for five
years free money that's really unheard
of considering just interest rates and
everything right now that is absolutely
incredible and we're excited that's just
the beginning too of some of the deals
that you have there and you have this
beautiful new store tell us about it
where it's at and where people need to
go if they want to take advantage of
some of these so 34 70 Boulder highways
where our new location is that is our
new Dodge Chrysler Ram store that opened
about three or four months ago but the
other great news is our exclusive Las
Vegas Chapman Jeep store opens in
January and that's come along it's gonna
be so cool Mercedes you wait where is
that going to be that is at 3175 East
Sahara so it's only 150 200 yards away
but we'll have our two stores set up
right there to service our customers now
some of these Black Friday deals that
you have early are they just on new cars
are they also on used cars so we have
some great specials on our used cars and
as we sell more new cars we take in more
used vehicle trades and some of these
trades are like brand new five six
fifteen thousand miles very very low
miles very well cared for and then we
put them through the Chapman process
before we sell them so there's great
deals on used cars but the specials that
are on new are what the Black Friday is
all about and you made this comment
earlier which I think it's so wonderful
inventory at a lot of dealerships is
still very low but not you guys you
still have have a lot to choose from we
do and you know part of that is the
commitment we've made by spending and
building on those new dealerships so our
manufacturers teleantis that makes the
Dodge Chrysler Jeep and RAM product gave
us additional product to support all the
expense that we've had and that helps us
just pass that on to our customers you
guys have been so successful I know your
customers love you so much why do you
think your customers just love you you
know we've developed a family atmosphere
people come in to buy a car it's a very
comfortable environment they know our
our sales representatives they know our
people in service so it's a family
feeling and we've earned their trust and
that's the biggest thing in the auto
Industries is being trustworthy and
you're not making them wait for a few
weeks to get these deals I love it Dawn
thank you so much get in on the Black
Friday deals Now call Chapman Dodge
Chrysler Jeep Ram at
702-457-1061 or visit lasvegasdodge.com
take advantage of their special offers
no payments until until February of 2023
and 11 000 off new Rams what a deal